[Music]
on today's show we talked to a dad who
wants to know if it's okay to date again
we talked to two different women who are
incredible and strong and they're
dealing with grief they're dealing with
regret and they're wondering what they
can do next stay tuned on the dr john
maloney show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john dolone's show i think
my voice is cracked today i'm going
through puberty that's good
and
james this morning i noticed when i got
to work that i had shaved and i missed a
spot
you know like like ugh where is it
it's like
okay everybody watching let's look i can
just oh man kelly you do that all the
time like you'll miss a big spot on your
chin
oh yeah that happens a lot
but it does happen to girls when we
shave our legs and then you're wearing
like a short skirt or shorts and then
you're like oh man oh man and you feel
like everyone can see it yeah james does
that both on his face and his legs i saw
ken shaven in the in the
like personalities are back there do you
not have a razor here
no i like to do that at home and i just
think [ __ ] sharing razors i didn't mean
sure
but surely that's how you get it
surely they're like breathing in the
same room
uh vaccinations and by the way don't
share mock threes because that's that's
like
that's how new variants are born i think
by sharing face raisers maybe not maybe
that's how you get get pass along
antibod i don't know pass along
antibodies i'll write a paper on it it's
good so we have a new guy working the uh
another news act
working the uh nasa screens over there
if you could see incompetence in action
you would see what i'm looking at
he's handsome let's don't get him wrong
he's he's the best-looking guy we've had
back brutal
i'm just kidding i know
by incompetence i meant
stunning and uh really good
and talented
thank you
and full of words
full of words that's so good um all
right hey real quick before we get to
the calls i y'all know i read a lot i
read this book the other day called um
solve for happy by mo gadot
g-a-w-d-a-t
i cannot recommend this highly enough it
was y'all know i i don't i got a problem
with the word happy and all that
um this guy's the chief who i think he
was the chief business officer at google
and then uh ended up taking on google x
he is brilliant at a level that i cannot
um understand and this book is really
extraordinary after the passing of his
son as he wrapped his head around it it
was really extraordinary
um mogadd jw d-a-t the book's called
solve for happy um i've got no stake in
it no nothing just that was one i put
down actually at the end of it i called
my son down i was listening to it
and uh asked him to come down and listen
to some parts of it um it was it was
that good so it's really remarkable but
cool let's get right to the calls today
we don't need to hear about me talking
about shaving and my hygiene well we're
like 11 minutes into the show and it's
like now let's get to the calls write to
him let's get right to him let's go to
drew in tulsa what's up brother drew
hi thanks for having me on your show you
bet man thanks for calling how's tulsa
it's warm very warm and would you
tell kelly i don't think a man has ever
noticed an unshaved spot on a woman's
legs when they wear a miniskirt
i'll let you do that
she's like dude brother she's mean man
she's me she's not mean she's really
kind and
she
all that she was very nice she was very
nice was
she was that like man just tell me about
what i'm just kidding hey so what's up
man how can i help
is it acceptable for me to start dating
again
tell me about it
so i am
i'm a single father of a teenage
daughter
the mother is absentee um
and she and i have been together for the
past
nine plus years
i'm in my mid-50s
[Music]
and recently through the power of
facebook i reconnected
with
maybe my first love from almost 35 years
ago awesome um
yeah and it's like we never were apart
it just clicked it was it's awesome
we've been talking regularly
um
we both have made it clear that it would
be nice to see each other but um i made
a commitment to never date until my
daughter becomes an adult or at least
for college
you know i've seen some evidence that
um especially daughters can have
challenges when
um parents bring new people into the
home
and so i just want to let her know that
hey i'm here for you i'm my i'm
dedicated to you
and um
yeah i didn't want her to have any of
those complications it was a it was a
challenging situation from when we were
when i was previously married so well
man i first and foremost dude what a
what an extraordinary guy and
part of me feels ridiculous for like
we're in a we're in a culture now where
it's extraordinary for a dad to step in
and love his daughter and be stay
connected to her as a single parent for
a decade
that's i feel dumb saying way to go man
and at the same time way to go man
that's incredible good for you
um thank you so
you love this little girl you all have a
pretty tight bond
it's pretty good there's been some
challenges that she's hit her teenage
years but i understand that's pretty
common dude i i
my daughter hit five and i don't even
know what happened so yeah
the teenage years i've read about them
and i can only see the the trainer
coming coming around the bend right at
us yeah i missed the days when she would
come running to the door every time i
came home so yeah man hey that will
return that will circle back on you man
um so
i
the hundred percent 1 000
yes
you can start dating
um in fact i would encourage it i would
encourage single parents that one of the
most important things they can do
for
their children
is to have relationships and connection
themselves for them to be well right so
yes 100
where i think things get off the track
off the rails are number one there's a
parade of new people
people start in front of young kids
people um
get infatuated and you get excited and
your heart races i could hear it in your
voice you're talking about this girl we
connect my first love like all that
stuff starts coming back and you start
saying things like you said in middle
school like i love her and we're going
to be together forever that kind of
stuff which is super fun it feels
awesome
a 16 year old
is immediately gonna go what about me
and that's not a moral or character
issue that's a development i mean that's
just developmentally correct you're her
anchor
and so
it will be on you to be open and honest
about
here's she knows what what dating's like
right she knows what being wanted is
like and what loneliness is like she
gets that she's 16. it's you being open
and honest and telling her in a way that
uh my friend rachel cruz says cher don't
scare right you don't want to say like
hey man i just i haven't kissed a girl
you know what you want to be gross about
it right but at the same time let her
know man i've been lonely and um
i've
i'm thinking about getting back out
there and talk to her about it and be
open about it and what you the gift you
can give her that will pay off
generationally for your family line will
be
um
teaching her how to have a conversation
and how to be nervous again and then
maybe invite her into this and say
things like hey is this the right way to
say this i haven't dated in a decade or
i don't know you know i mean those kind
of things that kind of bring her along
for the ride and at the end of the day
she might stamp her feet and she might
say how dare you and anan
she's 16 and at the end of the day she
doesn't get a vote right and that's
that's you've lived in a world where
you're trying to make up for the fact
that her mom left her and you're trying
to make up for trying to make up for and
you can't really do that right but it
feels good and i know you've been
working hard you can't fill that gap
there's always gonna be that gap and so
um yeah man feel free to date be honest
and
not too honest but honest
and
seek your daughter's feedback but
remember that she's 16 and she doesn't
get a vote does that make you nervous or
is this kind of been an excuse or
where's your heart at them this deal
you know i made a pretty firm commitment
not to date um
so i really
i would
if you had said no don't date it's going
to destroy your daughter i'd had no
problem going okay i'm not going to date
i've committed to that but you know you
get the
butterflies in your tummy and you know
it's it's kind of fun thinking oh i
might reconnect so no man but i have no
i have no problem committing to her and
not to commit to my daughter and saying
no i'm gonna wait for two more years
that's not a problem have you talked to
her about it
no
i think that would be worth the
conversation is she she has no contact
with mom mom left you all and is just
out of the picture
uh she has infrequent contact mother
lives about 1500 miles away
wow
what does she what does she think about
her mom
okay um
the brief version is there were some
issues with the mother's health some
addiction issues
and so um after going through a divorce
uh
we moved to be near my support system
apart across the other side of the
country
and the mother as soon as she's recently
come back around
i'm sorry your question is what does my
daughter think about her she's been
through phases where she never wanted to
talk to her didn't want anything to do
with her um i encourage you to stay in
contact they went through some
troublesome premiums periods recently
it's gotten better but it's still real
in frequent contact okay
um so
expect there to be some trauma there and
some hurt there that's not related to
you but that will end up all over you
you know that right
right right and that will be separate
and apart from
dating and not all kids but many kids
especially young children and especially
early teens
hold on to a fantasy that maybe one day
my parents will get back together
and there's something about dating that
does trigger that oh no this is this is
over and sometimes that finality is hard
in your daughter's situation that that
period may be at the end of that
sentence a long long time ago you know
what i mean
and so every kid is going to be
different i think it
it leans on adults to be adults
and if you abandon your daughter in this
process and you get so infatuated and
you're just staring at your phone all
day and facebooking all day and calling
all day and leaving for trips and
yeah that can be a problem
if you
date like a grown-up and you treat your
daughter like a grown-up and she's your
priority but at the same time you're
showing her hey dad's gonna be in a
relationship too and i'm nervous and
should i wear this and hey is this the
right way to text this back bring her
along there man it could be a really
remarkable connecting tool for you two
and she may just say screw you i'm going
back to mom i hate you i've always hated
you whatever and she's 16
and the daughter of a mom who
left them and left her and who had
addiction issues and so there's gonna
just be some trauma there um it and so
it's trying to solve for every one of
those variables it's gonna be really
hard you know your daughter better than
anybody
you also know that
and you've been alone for a decade and
that's a long long time and sometimes
after trauma
after heart heartache and heartbreak we
make these really firm i'm not gonna
until
and sometimes those service
they serve us well in the moment they
provide a concrete foundation for us for
a minute to let us anchor in and then go
on about healing and moving on and
sometimes they served their purpose well
before um that are our fake deadlines
that we set on ourselves so brother i
mean if you find somebody talk to her i
don't have any i have no
psychological problems with dating your
daughter's gonna have her own challenges
based on stuff that happened way before
this sounds like she's got an awesome
dad who loves her um and man bring her
along in a gentle and uh
compassionate way we'll see what happens
thank you so much for the call brother
hey we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone's show
[Music]
hey what's up this delony let's talk
about getting a good night's sleep it's
important for your physical health your
mental health your relation health for
your sanity you name it sleep is
important if you're not sleeping good
one of the first questions i want you to
ask is do i need a new mattress
here's how you tell are you tossing and
turning all night cause you can't get
comfortable are you waking up in the
middle of the night burning hot or in
the morning does your back hurt if you
have any of these issues you may need a
new mattress
check out dream cloud it's a mattress i
have in my own house you will love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer of all time
400 bucks in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount only for delony
listeners that's a total of 650 bucks in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress shipped to
your house today and you can enjoy 650
bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com
promo code d-e-l-o-n-y
all right we are back let's go to nikki
in
denver colorado
what's up nikki
thanks for taking my call dr john thanks
for calling how in the world are you
i'm doing all right very cool so what's
up
um
so about three and a half years ago
my dad committed suicide
lately over
um i would say maybe the last year
i've dealt with a lot of
guilt around not being able to help my
dad um when i saw that he was struggling
yeah and my question is
how can i
sorry oh you're good take your time
how do i pull myself out of those
spirals that i get myself into of
feeling guilty and
responsible for not being able to help
my dad
i'm so sorry
that's hard
tell me about your dad tell me about him
growing up
um
he was funny
yeah he
was a really fun dad he was in law
enforcement so
you know his job was hard and there were
a lot of times that were hard growing up
but um
i loved my dad i loved my dad
and
the last few years of our relationship
were really strained because he was
pretty sick
and
um
so that was hard but
as a kid i loved i loved my dad yeah
what about your mom what role did she
play in your childhood
um my mom was also great both both of my
parents were around growing up um
my mom was kind of my spiritual anchor
growing up
and
she was kind of the one that run ran the
household and
um
you know as a teenager i had a pretty
strong relationship with my mom but now
dave she's my best friend and i i love
my mom a lot that's cool he's been my
rock through a lot so what happened four
five six years ago you said you saw your
dad got sick and you saw
a shift in his personality tell me about
that
um
so
when i was a kid my dad had an accident
and he
ended up on
pain medication um to help manage the
pain from this accident
and
um
i didn't know it until much later in my
life but
he became really dependent on pain
medication was that when you were a kid
too
that was when i was a kid but a lot of
the issues from it didn't manifest until
at least not from what i could tell
until i was
a teenager okay
and then over time it just got worse and
worse and then a few years ago what was
the circumstances around him taking his
taking his life
um
[Applause]
he
he just struggled with
not only physical pain but
just
emotional and mental health yeah
um
being in law enforcement my dad was not
one to reach out for help
um
it was just a stigma that i was very
aware of growing up
um you know
he he
felt that
asking for help showed weakness and
even when he really needed it
i don't think he knew how to ask or even
accept help that's right and i've spent
my life around police officers and
you're exactly right that's one of the
yeah biggest challenges um
that that community faces is being able
to raise your hand and say hey i'm i'm
drowning here yeah i need some help yeah
how old are you
uh i'm 27 27 and you have a family you
buy you live by yourself you get little
kids like tell me where you are in life
i am single as the day i was born
i'm i'm i uh live by myself um my mom
and my younger brother still live close
but um
yeah i live out on my own now and
i'm
doing well for the most part i have a
good job i am rooted in a good church
and i so what does this debilitation
feel like
when you start thinking about it walk me
through some of the thoughts that pop
into your head
it almost feels like panic sometimes
yeah um i've gone through a lot of my
own health journeys over the last couple
years just
trying to get my own
physical and mental health and a good
place
not that it's ever been super bad but
you know i've always wanted to do better
for myself and
i think as i learn more about how to
keep myself well
i think about the things that i could
have done for my dad to try to help him
be well
um
and so i just
it gets to a place where
i end up sitting in my guilt for
sometimes a couple days
um
so
let me
you and i could sit down for a couple of
hours and
really dig into some stuff and so i'm
gonna take a few of the things you said
and do a flyby here
um
and i may be wrong on a few things
but i've sat with a number of folks in
your situation so tell me if i'm right
okay and if i'm wrong please call me out
okay but when you grow up in the home of
someone who's fun
and hilarious and they work a traumatic
job and
they're an addict
for a young child
the memories can be about the silliness
and the fun sometimes the volatility
like that occasional burst of anger and
you're like whoa
but what your brain and your heart
detect is that detachment
your brain and your heart
and this is a physiological thing this
isn't some
emotional thing
it knows that your dad is
six klonopin into an evening
or five oxies into an evening
it knows that he you are in the presence
of your father and he's not there
because he's high
your little kid brain sees him and sees
that smile that fake half half sleepy
smile that is silly and come on up and
let's cuddle
but your brain knows we're disconnected
and for the child of an addict this is
with alcohol this is with any number of
things
this is with parents who nowadays just
are so busy with work they're just
scrolling on their phones 24 7 365 and
their kid is staring at them and they're
talking to them but they know they're
not present
and your
brain will literally try to solve that
connection
forever forever
because
your body and your brain knows that guy
loves me he says he loves me he's here
but i can feel there's a
gulf between us it must be my fault
and that's you hear me say all the time
that's what five-year-olds and
seven-year-olds they try to solve that
disconnection problem especially with
with parents who have traumatic jobs
especially with parents who struggle
with mental health issues especially
with parents who struggle with addiction
and now you fast forward
to one of the most tragic things
which is a father who loves his daughter
and got to a place in his heart and his
head that said i don't want to die
but i need this to stop and
i think my daughter's life will be
better with me not here
and that math doesn't make sense to you
because you know that's not true but it
made sense in his head and in his heart
and here's what your
sweet brain and heart is still trying to
do
number one it's still trying to bridge
that gap
you're still trying to solve him
and number two the even scarier thing is
our brains solve for control
that's what anxiety is that's what all
that depression is is our brain solving
for control
and you can't control this
and so what it will do it will it will
reach back and try to say well we should
have and really what that is it's a
protective mechanism to say if it ever
happens again then
if i ever love recklessly and deeply
again i will make sure that
and exhale
you can't and i'm so sorry because it
feels so powerless right
yeah
and
you may have heard me say this before we
spend so much energy and this isn't just
you this is all of us we spend so much
energy with a pen in our hand
trying to go back and edit sentences
of our lives that have already been
written with periods at the end of those
sentence and you can't edit them
the only thing on earth we can do is
write a new one right
right
my guess is did you go to your dad's
funeral
so
we didn't have a traditional funeral for
him okay
um dad always wanted to be cremated so
we cremated him as all cops do it's the
weirdest thing man
i don't understand i don't either every
cop i know is like no just cremate me
we'll move on like
golly like we want to do more for you
than that but you know i mean we wanted
to honor what he had always told us
because i mean as a cops kid you grow up
with the realization that you know at
any point in time something could happen
every day could be the day exactly it
was a conversation that was very open in
our house and um so we we cremated him
and
um we had some family and we
we um
spread his ashes uh in one of his
favorite spots where we grew up
so we didn't really have a traditional
funeral but you know we did do something
okay
does your mom still miss him
i think she does um
they had a really
strange relationship especially in the
last five or six years
but my dad was here
so when he got real sick
yeah
um so the last thing i'll tell you is
this and then i'll walk you through a
couple things you can do
um
when i've
worked with young people
and here's unfortunately you're still a
young person because i'm old now when
i've worked with young people
there's this lingering thing in the back
of their head that says could this
happen to me
could i get to a place where
things were so cloudy and so gray
that i could do this
and that's a really scary thing have you
ever been there
you know good
i want you to stay committed to
you getting well which is really
extraordinary that you've branched out
to do that
stay committed to that journey okay
so in all honesty my guess is
you haven't let him go yet
you did the funeral that he wanted
and you are still have a little girl in
you trying to solve his love
and trying to make sure he's okay
because that was your job that's a lot
of kids job when their parents are
addicts and their parents are struggling
with mental health issues it's to make
sure they're okay
and there's a part of your heart and
mind that thinks you failed
and i need you to hear you did not fail
you didn't you loved that man and that
man loved you
and as you said it you said it's so
great he was sick and he died by suicide
and
when you let him go
the greatest gift you can give your old
man is to go live fully and love
correctlessly
and to be the little girl
um and grow up into the extraordinary
woman i know you are
um
and live live live
practice practically speaking i know it
sounds so easy you're like cool man but
sometimes i wake up on tuesdays and i
can't breathe right
yeah
like all these little cliche things
some of this is gonna be and again i
feel like i'm a broken record sometimes
um i just have seen this be so cathartic
in my personal life but in so many other
folks
is
whether you keep a journal
if i'm you here's what i do and i've
said this recently i would go over pay
and you may have already done this i'd
go over pay for a fancy pants leather
journal
and it would just be letters to dad
and when you wake up in the morning and
you can't breathe i'd write him a note
write him a letter
and when you are having a good coming up
on a birthday that you wish you were
there or you meet some somebody that
you're attracted to and you want to talk
to him about it write it down
and what you're going to do is you're
going to begin your brain will begin to
recognize we're safe we're here
and it will stop sounding all the alarms
as though there's a still present
emergency because there's not but your
brain's still acting like it is
yeah i also want you to
spend four or five
weeks
maybe once a week
i want you to write a letter to
little nikki
i did this recently and it was really
profound i wrote some letters to john as
a kid 14 year old john 7 year old john
and i let john know that he's a good kid
and it wasn't his job to fill in the
blank xyz
and yeah that was a mean thing that he
said and i was nine right
there was just some letting me off the
hook and i want you to write young nicki
some stories some letters
and let her know that she did the best
she could
she's a kid
she deserved better and she
was loved by her mom and her dad and she
just grew up in a chaotic situation
i really want you to stay connected to
a counselor during this tough season
at some point when you're writing
letters to your dad you're going to get
really really angry have you been there
yet
a few times good
i want you to know that's not
dishonoring of him
okay it's okay to be really really angry
and when you
um have your first little baby or you
get your first big promotion you say i'm
gonna have any kids i'm just gonna go be
a rock star what
he should have been there and he's not
yeah and so it's okay to be angry and
it's okay to grieve then it's okay to be
really really sad about that
yeah and give yourself permission to
slowly
open the shades back up and then here's
the last thing
laughter enjoy
and dating and
christmases and new presents and jumping
up and down and screaming because you're
excited about something
is not a dishonoring of your dad
yeah and there's those moments when you
feel joy and then you feel like you're
not supposed to have joy because this
happened is that right
uh sometimes you know
yeah you deserve joy and laughter and
happiness
and when the grief waves come you
breathe and you go
man i miss him
and you grab that little journal and you
say dad i miss you i wish you were here
today
but i'm living like i'm living i'm
living like a wild lady just like you
trained me except i'm driving the speed
limit dad i am good grief
and
i'm a cops kid too so i get it um
and
i'm doing all the thing right but i miss
you
and then what you're gonna find is that
grief that wave it's gonna feel like an
ocean it's gonna come over you and it
will go from lasting all morning
lasting three days
to lasting
30 minutes
to lasting five minutes
and then you're gonna come up with a
series of practices whether it's walking
whether it's texting somebody that you
love whether it is writing a quick note
whether it's just looking up in the sky
you're going to come up with a quick
series of things and over the next six
months year two years these cycles will
happen faster and faster
and it's hard and i'm so sorry that you
went through this but i need you to let
little nikki go
i need to let grown up nikki go and i
need you to live
live live that's the best way to honor
your dad
and if you're a police officer out there
if you love a police officer if you love
a fireman if you love somebody military
if you love somebody who
is um
in a marginalized population is
routinely not safe routinely having to
go to places where they are
under pressure
i need you
to
go get the help that you need
i need you to grab their face and look
them in the eye with both hands and say
i love you and i need you to call
somebody
the last couple years has been really
really hard a lot of different people
and i don't like getting phone calls
from buddies who say so and so passed
away whipped by suicide and their police
officers and firemen and military folks
and the police officers that i still
work with and talk to and they are
struggling
that members of my community that are on
the margins are struggling
please get the help you need
thank you so so much nikki for your
honesty and for openness
and then healings around the corner
we'll be right back on the dr john the
woman's show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back let's take one
more call let's go to elizabeth in
newport oregon hey elizabeth what's
going on
uh hi dr dalonia it's an honor to talk
to you it is more of an honor to talk to
you i promise how's it going
oh it's
it's going better than it i deserve
excellent excellent so what's up how can
i help okay um so
geez this gets pretty complicated okay
um so i'll uh just kind of start with my
questions
um i'm dealing with
quite a bit of regret following a
divorce
and
i'm also
having issues
um
dealing with now that i am divorced um
the thought of having children i
basically got a second chance to have
children if i wanted them
um so that's
yeah
so how long have you been divorced
um less less than a year okay why'd you
get divorced
uh well some brief context um i'm a long
time ramsay listener um i'm debt free
and uh this is basically
a whole year of gazelle intensity like
all coming in at once all coming down at
once
basically starting in 2019 my mother and
brother both passed away both from
mental illness and addiction
and right in the middle of that is when
my divorce was going down
what precipitated that divorce
somebody cheat on somebody you all just
i just didn't like each other anymore
what was it oh god it was a mess see
i guess the biggest thing with the
divorce was like i mean we we'd go on
through a bunch of things and then
what was it what was it what was it
you've got like there's like two things
what are they
um
well
i would say the biggest issue is
probably like my severe body dysmorphia
okay
um
and then just
our just our inability like we did
everything wrong basically all
everything that you know dave ramsey
talks i mean you guys talk about it too
like we moved in together before we were
married we got a house before we were
married we had debt
like we didn't combine finances like it
was all and i went head to head with my
in-laws a bunch of times which is stupid
like i learned a lot of lessons like so
there's just a lot of pressure on this
relationship early on and then in the
middle of it's a lot of grief and if you
grow up in a home where you've got a
mother with
with
mental health challenges and your
brother's got mental health challenges
and there's addiction then um
you may have picked up some
different pictures and different models
that weren't healthy
and um not to mention whatever genetic
components and all that stuff whatever
abuse and stuff you suffered and so
there was a lot of pressure on this
thing and you
said i didn't take a break
is that right or i'm out
or he said i'm out
and we both i mean we both did like he
basically when we were talking about
divorce like he offered to reconcile and
i just said no and then a couple months
into that the separation i tried to
reconcile twice and he said no so then
we like just went through with it and
then i sold my house paid off my debt
bought a van moved across the country
like literally to the west coast from
new york
uh
and lived in the van off-grid for four
months i've been living awkward for four
months in a van
down by a river please say yes please
say yes literally literally really
that's fantastic literally down by a
river elizabeth yes
i'm gonna start calling you matt foley
all right so
um
there's an old saying in
counseling
which is the tyranny of accomplishing
all of your dreams
right um and
you're not accomplishing all of your
dreams but
kind of one of the worst things that
happens when we make major life changes
whether that's taking a new job um
cheating on our spouses with somebody
who finally is acknowledging that that
we're good looking or that we're lovable
or that they make us feel sexy again or
moving across the country in a van down
by a river whatever the thing is paying
off all of your debts whatever the thing
is
what catches
millions of people off guard
is that when you reach these new
milestones
you go with you
yeah and you
experienced
deep tragedy and if you grew up in the
house of an addict or somebody with
mental health challenges
you also grew up not liking your mom
sometimes probably hating your mom
sometimes and then you have to reconcile
that with the grief you feel because
your mom died and then you've got that
guilt on top of you and then your
brother and all those things and i
should have said i could haves and here
we are in this grief and now
my in-laws are idiots and my husband and
i
are
just
stumbling through this thing right
and i'm just gonna run and the problem
is
you showed up in that van down by the
river on the west coast right
yeah and he came with me in my brain
like yeah like all of this regret is
basically as i do a lot of dream
recording i pay attention to my dreams
and like i get
these just invasive persistent dreams
about marriage
and like
it's almost brought me to the point
where i reached out to him to see you
know to try again but like who wants
that phone call like i don't want to be
you know the ex that calls you back like
i just don't feel that would be
appropriate like we had as many reasons
to
to continue the divorce as to stay
together like there were so many things
and like now yeah i don't see i don't
buy that
you all chose to get divorced and
when it comes to reasons and things i
mean
i just seen couples work through the
most insane things
and so you can point to it's because of
this it's because of this it's because
of this but at the end of the day
it was because you don't want to be with
that person anymore
and so it's like well it's not like a
teeter-totter or like a scale where
you're like well there's just many
reasons to stay and this many reasons no
you just left and he left
and so
it sounds to me like you are desperately
painfully
and probably pathologically lonely
and you are exhausted
definitely that one and you are scared
and you are completely and totally alone
and
you may have gotten divorced because you
were in the middle of a hurricane and
you just left home like i gotta get out
of here and now the hurricane has passed
and you're coming you're interested in
going back and see if you're home still
standing all that stuff's
i mean that you're not crazy and you're
not wrong and who wants that phone call
he may desperately be dreaming of that
phone call
or you may be making that phone call um
because you're desperate
either way what i would tell you is in
this moment in history be true to
yourself
and if you miss him call him and say i
miss you
if it wasn't abusive if it wasn't
violent if it wasn't those things that
um where you are codependent and
um
you know what i mean it sounds like you
all left on weird terms like you still
love the guy and he still loves you and
y'all just found yourself on a train
moving west and you just didn't get off
it's some of that i mean so
this i mean it's true but like so much
because i've basically been
doing so much research on marriage and
family and everything in the last year
and like if i knew then what i know now
about marriage how my opinions about
marriage have changed like i would have
tried way harder
and some of this may be grief some of
this may be
guilt
some of it may be regret
and it may be less connected to him and
more connected to you
uh it sure could be like this
other this other question that i
struggle so much with with this whole
divorce is like we were 100 on the same
page 100 on the same page about not
having children and like that sort of
changed for me now a little so i got
this like whole opportunity to like have
kids again if i wanted but
my i come from a family of like
borderline personality disorder
agoraphobia obesity like opiate
addiction alcoholism and like i am like
i'm afraid to like how does a person
know if they're too crazy to have
children like is that a
like
i don't that's that's what i struggle
with a lot too because i'm 36 like i
could easily have another relationship
and like
are you too crazy to have children
i
would love to find out
like i'm i just
it seems so easy to screw up children
like
one of the best ways you can one of the
best ways you can love and honor
children
is by first loving and honoring yourself
okay and by being well
and by doing the work to be well what
you've done over the last year is you
ran
and i'm not gonna say running in your
situation wasn't the right thing
you have not dealt at all with elizabeth
you've read some books
you have got some new information you've
thought about a lot of things
and you're literally in a van down by a
river
what you haven't done
is learn how to be in relationship
in new information is helpful it's
really helpful
but it won't heal you
it just helps you it's like a gps system
it helps you find the right road but you
got to walk that road
and that is relationship
and what you don't have a model for in
your family history
is how to do relationship how to be at
peace how to be well
for sure and you've got a lot of
childhood traumas my guess you've got a
lot of adult trauma is my guess
turns out
yeah
and
that's okay
your past is not going to determine your
future if you don't want it to
is it going to be hard oh my gosh yes
are you gonna have to work really hard
to get new models and to get new
relationships and to practice
living healthy a healthy life in a way
that you've never even seen done before
yeah you are
and by the way you're allowed to make
wild intense proclamations when you're
28 and change your mind when you're 29.
that happens
i'm never having kids
that's what it was basically yeah and
then you hold your first kid with your
buddy has a kid and you go
oh yeah
you know what i mean
or i'm never moving to that town because
that town suit and i live in that town
uh i love the way esther perel says it
she says most adults will have three or
four
deep loves in their lifetime and if they
work really really hard
it'll be with the same person and
personally right i'm actually a fan of
her yes i've heard that and so what you
what happened is
y'all stop working at it
yeah
and so here's what i want you to do i
want you to immediately
today
reach out to somebody
whether that's a counselor whether
that's at betterhelp.com
whether that's a local pastor
whether that's a mentor or a friend
and i want you to say the words
i need to learn how to be in
relationship with somebody
okay and if you missed your ex-husband
call him
you're 2 500 miles apart or 6 000 or
wherever i don't know where you all are
you're way far apart from each other and
the worst he can say is i don't want to
talk to you
i've moved on i'm married to somebody
else
all of that relationship is a risk
but what you're doing is you're making
yourself a little bit bonkers with the
unknown
am i too crazy to have a kid should i
have gotten divorced but
just move forward
with healing
just move forward with
hey how are you man
how's it going
i miss you just want you to know
and he may say
you're bananas or he may say i've been
waiting for this phone call for however
many months and it's probably honestly
it's probably
um
i don't i don't even want to guess i
didn't want to guess you had so much
trauma in 2019 and you had so much
trauma leading up to 2019 and then we've
had 2020 and 2021
and you had a divorce in the middle of
that in unsupportive in-laws and your
own mental health challenges and your
own addiction challenges i don't there's
so much going on a lot yeah
actually you know what i'm gonna
i know the uh the the internet warriors
are gonna
be mad at me i'm gonna tell you to pause
for a second before you call him
i want you to call a counselor first and
sit down and talk to somebody
for the first time and i want you to
if you can at all stop living in a van
down by a river go get an apartment
and get a full-time job and work real
hard
and start reconnecting with people
start reconnecting with human beings and
be in a relationship with them and this
is going to be hard
and if you can get with a counselor who
will walk through this with you or a
great mentor that you trust and someone
who's going to hold you accountable and
call you on your crap and isn't going to
let you just be like yeah you go girl no
that's going to say
that's not how we talk to people
and it may be that you end up in a
medical doctor's office
to get some medical care
and to get a team of people who can help
and by the way this is expensive and i
know that i'm not behind the sky
someone's listening to this saying i
don't have that kind of money i get that
it's hard
there are resources out there for you if
you want to if you want that healing and
they are hard to find
um
but i'll tell you this elizabeth and
i'll say to everybody else listening
you're worth finding those things
to answer the question am i too crazy to
have a baby i can't answer that
i can't answer that
um
i've seen people become extraordinary
and remarkable and powerful
when they're holding kids and i've seen
really brilliant wonderful people have
kids and they just regress and become
four-year-olds themselves and so that
question is hard and so i'm never gonna
just make a blanket statement like that
i will tell you you're worth healing
and you're worth
staring down that generation terry reel
calls it a forest fire of dysfunction
that has raged through your family
for generations now
and somebody has to have the courage to
turn and face that forest fire and say
it stops with me and elizabeth that
could be you
that can be you
and it will be hard and the goal here is
if you do have kids that their road is
easier to walk than yours is
because you're saying no more
and if you don't have kids you're still
worth it
you're still worth it
and if you made a mistake call him
after you've done some relational work
and you've got a chance to breathe and
you're not sleeping in a van call him
say hey i miss you but that's that's for
down the road a little bit
down the road
i love it when when in my life when i
look in the mirror and say i was wrong i
need to go fix that i love that i love
that
every what's the old meditation thing
every moment is a chance to every time i
have a breath
i have a chance to say i'ma start over
and i'm going to start over and i'm
going to start over
i'm proud of you for making the call
elizabeth now i'm going to be really
proud of you because it's time for you
to be courageous and go do the hard
healing stuff
as we wrap up today's show
[Laughter]
sorry elizabeth this this one's a little
bit too close
it's the song we got man i got two songs
here both of them would not be great for
you elizabeth and so
i'm gonna go with the least not great
one
so off the 2008 fearless album
taylor swift absolutely are you
impressed that i knew based on the album
title that i don't want to be impressed
or really depressed one of the two i'm
an unashamed taylor swift fan i am too
what a songwriter
off the 20 2008 fearless
album was her
and some boy on a balcony
and it was a love story and it goes like
this
we were both young when i first saw you
i closed my eyes and the flashback
starts i'm standing there on a balcony
where in summer air
see the lights see the party see the
ball gown see the see you make your way
through the crowd and you say hello
little did i know that you were romeo
and you were throwing pebbles and my
daddy said stay away from juliet and i
was crying on the staircase begging you
please don't go
and i said romeo take me somewhere we
can be alone i'll be waiting
all there's left to do is run you be the
prince and i'll be the princess it's a
love story baby just say yes
and then eventually he says yes yadda
yadda
elizabeth this may not be about you
don't do something weird because i just
did this song right here on the dr john
de loni show
you